we are here in the beautiful city of
Kyoto Japan taking pictures of cherry
blossoms and eating our way through this
city we've had okonomiyaki food on soba
but we have yet to try the one place
that arguably has the best food in all
of Japan 7-eleven baby
[Music]
so there's a reason why these
convenience stores or konbini as they're
called are so popular one they are
everywhere I mean there was three within
walking distance of our hotel - they are
incredibly cheap and three the food
quality is super-high and the packaging
is really dope we've got a hundred
dollars the BuzzFeed's money and it's
lunchtime I have an apple watch let's do
this this is the most excited I've ever
been for a taste test
let's also address fact that I look like
at home for this video I know those are
gonna be the top comments so just get
out of the way the counter food at
7-eleven America it's disgusting it's
like corn dogs and nachos this already
like looks better this is like when you
I've had a couple of saccades and you
just need to run in and grab something
quick grab one or two of these and you'd
be good to go together
yeah wet you know pizza without hard
crust like if the crust is just kind of
wet down down down looks like someone
came on your face I'm okay with it man
[Music]
that was fun this is good for any age
you're a kid you like this your old lady
with no teeth you like this look how fun
this is oh now it's a plate Japan oh man
right if I could pass on any Street
Market right even though it's a packaged
item this is the first thing I feel like
I've had that stale Wow
hello Brian Wow now this is eggs that
you could put in your ramen but they're
so perfect that you can just eat them on
your own - oh good luck with the Hat oh
damn she's white but she can use
chopsticks
it tastes like ramen yeah like whatever
sauce that's in perfect center
it comes with sauce it takes to the
front do what make the dream work that's
where we're a good couple be perfect
yeah Wow coca-cola and lemon in vitamins
i weirdly taste the vitamin like a
Flintstone
chalky vitamin telephony warm planning
on getting wasted for this video but as
any consider Buzzard video goes come
friendship mother bear Nick and that's
beer thank you
these looking really good oh it's so
soft
yeah mochi what no you got the powdered
sugar texture you got the mochi texture
if they got the red bean texture oh man
that's good
mm-hmm I don't mind at all I'm not
feeling it it's gonna be enough of me
dog where's Elizabeth Holmes would say
that's going to be a no for me dog that
looks like them she'd get an American
7-eleven ready shout out to Mike Chen
strictly EE he's the one who introduced
me to all this 7-eleven goodness oh if
you're comparing this to cup noodles
it's the best cup of noodles at pass
level can you compare it to like your
one-star yelp review drown in place like
no I still think that would be better
than this
I love a good kimchi
[Music]
you mean kimchi when we go have like
Korean barbeque I think just no okay
they've sort of coagulated into like a
caterpillar like dumpling they're not
crisp you know it's aspiring to be good
for sure
[Music]
there goes well I gotta be honest these
noodles I would take over the Michelin
rated ramen any day very popular item in
the 7-eleven so you see boobies beating
this just all over the street sorry I
don't know why I said it though a full
one cold too
oh yeah I really just want to we're not
from here it's kind of a just a filler
that's really good that's Manila flavor
I've ever had
damn they don't blow up late for work
that's right I like that if you aren't
finished Japan
[Applause]
if you like matcha can you hear that
it's like dense how could I hear Dunson
they look like cubed fruits which
confused us which is why we bought them
pure apple flavored gummy bear I'm gonna
throw this in your mouth oh my god
mafia we like chewy this is the best I
have ever had including sex all right
guys no I'm good let's get in one of
these mother-effing sandwiches that was
the ex thic seat cutlet so not only is
there like a whipped cream there's a
custard in there too and those
strawberries what was it that front I
bet someone just made this pastry I'm
gonna save this I'm gonna eat that what
do you want
you better not be mouthing to the camera
that you're gonna eat it nope you better
not be nothing yes nope the moment
you've all been waiting for the egg
salad 7/11 mother switch
we know what all the comments are gonna
say losses egg salad sandwich is so much
better than 7-eleven don't worry we've
got you covered baby this is a bonus
round well once you blind taste-test
both of the egg salad sandwiches and we
can finally put rest the debate who has
a better egg salad sandwich Lawson's
or 7-eleven as it closed go ahead and
open your eyes
whoa they do look like the same okay I
need to cleanse my palate insert fancy
music here please so we're gonna try the
left side first very nice balance of
chunk of egg white and the bread soft
cleanse my palate Ian
there you go number two it's a little
more even the consistent consistencies
like we got chunks and evenly
distributed we're gonna pick our
favorites in three two one
Cantor your favorite one was the
7-eleven was about you and you came out
on top all right guys we ate our way
through the entire Kyoto 7-eleven thank
you so much Japan everything about you
is better than us where do you want us
to see next maybe go to another country
and try more 7-eleven
all right I gotta lay down
I will pay and you know got anybody
famine Japan go play these babies all
nice and ship under me is my recover
[Music]